so as far as I'm concerned the Younger
You Can Get Married the better because
you're saying like oh you've got you've
got to do this you might have to do
traveling you might have to do this you
have to do that you have to do this and
do that by the time you're 35. once you
you've done everything who wants you
you've got to think to yourself you're
looking at all these stars but what have
you got to offer a man at 35 when you've
been through everything and you've done
everything you've got all this history
behind you've got all this trauma
wouldn't it be easier while you're young
to get your head together and just say
right well I'm going to find someone
same level as me I'm going to get
married the early the better